[Music]
octopi tigers and stingray oh my here's
what you might have missed in the newest
season of Cobra Kai
at the beginning of Cobra Kai season 5
Daniel Larusso makes a difficult
decision and closes down his Miyagi doe
Dojo a condition of the bet he lost to
Terry silver in season four his students
are understandably bummed out and
Dimitri in particular has one
interesting throwaway line Greg guess
I'm getting a summer job
it's an easy line to miss but it
foreshadows a funny scene later on in
the season after returning from Mexico
Johnny decides to get a new phone so
that he can properly join the gig
economy he gets a knock on the door from
The Tech Guy who's supposed to help him
set it up and of course it's none other
than Dimitri this might seem like it
comes from out of nowhere if you missed
Dimitri's earlier line about getting a
job but if you caught that detail it
makes a lot of sense working the
fictional equivalent of The Geek Squad
desk is perfect for Dimitri and the
scene gives him a fun excuse to butt
heads with Johnny again just like in the
old days
one of the big running gags in Cobra Kai
is that Johnny Lawrence just doesn't
understand modern technology in the past
he struggled to understand Facebook
Google and laptops among other things
that confusion carries on into season
five he calls Google goggle in an
exchange with Daniel he plugs every
existential question he encounters into
the internet he achieves the worst
reviewed Uber profile ever in record
time but one particular scene calls back
to season two in an especially fun way
while delivering food orders around town
Johnny drops a box of taquitos off to
the owner of a local pawn shop a
character who fans of the show will
surely recognize in season 2 the same
guy sells Johnny his first computer and
subsequently has to help him figure out
the basics of how it works the pawn shop
proprietor plays the same role in season
5 by helping Johnny fix an issue with
his new smartphone it appears that some
things never change still Johnny manages
to effectively apply his Tech at a few
points in season five not only does his
phone help him find employment but he
uses the Treasure Trove of knowledge on
the internet to prepare for the coming
baby and to try to help Robbie and
Miguel reconcile not all of these plans
work out but it's nice to see him try
Miguel and Sam have a bit of a roller
coaster Arc in Cobra Kai season 5 Sam
gets upset when Miguel leaves her Mexico
without saying anything and when he gets
back he tries to make it up to her he
goes jewelry shopping in hopes of
finding a gift and he settles on a
peculiar piece a necklace with a pendant
in the shape of an octopus there is no
flashback scene or added explanation to
give context but fans of the show should
recognize the significance of the
necklace to Miguel and Sam's
relationship during their first date in
Cobra Kai season 1 Miguel wins a giant
stuffed octopus and presents it to Sam
jokingly as a gift it becomes a symbol
of their relationship moving forward so
it makes sense that Miguel would choose
an octopus necklace and it hurts to see
him throw it away fortunately Sam
stumbles upon it later on and the two
get back together by the end of the
season
there are a lot of capable karate
practitioners in Cobra Kai in a show
where Fierce fighters who cover a range
of Ages and styles thrown down in almost
every episode you'd think it would be
easy to tell how everyone Stacks up
against each other but Cobra Kai does a
good job of keeping things even Sam
beats Tori but with help from her
friends then Tori beats Sam but with a
dirty ref nearly every fight in the show
hints toward a clear way that the loser
could have won perpetuating debates
about who's the strongest one of the
biggest debates centers on whether
Miguel Robbie or Hawk is the strongest
of the main teenage boy characters they
each get moments in the spotlight and
they've faced off against each other
many times but in a subtle Way season 5
seems to confirm that Miguel is the best
fighter of the three at Johnny's urging
Miguel and Robbie hash out their beef in
a No Holds Barred battle Midway through
the season which ends in a mirror of
their season 2 School Duel it's clear
that Miguel has Robbie on the ropes even
after they both give it their all later
in the season finale Miguel goes
toe-to-toe with Kenny who defeated Hawk
several episodes prior and seems to get
the best of him as well in short
Miguel's not the one you want to mess
with
every main character gets some time for
growth and development in Cobra Kai
season 5 including Amanda Larusso in
episode 5 she takes a well-deserved
break from her husband's crazy karate
drama to reconnect with family
specifically her cousin Jessica Andrews
who devoted fans will recognize from The
Karate Kid Part 3. if you're not
intimately familiar with all the movies
this connection might tornado kick right
over your head but Jessica doesn't just
provide an unexpected Cameo she also
explains the significance of Terry
silver while catching up at a local bar
the two women discuss how Jessica and
Daniel were tormented by the evil sensei
in the past Terry silver is back you
know Terry silver as far as how Daniel
and Amanda met apparently Jessica moved
back to Ohio after the events of The
Karate Kid Part 3 but she and Daniel
clearly remained friends which
ultimately led to Amanda's introduction
to the Miyagi dough owner while a small
detail this is a fun inclusion because
it finally connects Amanda to the larger
Karate Kid timeline it also gives
Jessica a character who doesn't get to
do much in the original film a slightly
more important role in the franchise
than she previously held
when the Miyagi doe and Eagle Fang
students come to Stingray for help at
the end of Cobra Kai season 5. he's
wearing an interesting t-shirt if you've
played the original The Legend of Zelda
or are simply familiar with the memes
you'll probably recognize the phrase
it's dangerous to go alone take this
printed on the shirt the line is spoken
by the NPC who gives link his sword in
the NES game and it's become iconic in
the decades since this choice of
clothing can be interpreted simply as a
good choice for DND night which is what
Stingray is up to at the time however
there's a decent bit of thematic depth
that we can read into the shirt on one
level the line is an echo of the
resounding season 5 message that doing
hard things alone is rarely a good idea
be it Johnny and Daniel or Tori and Sam
the season makes a point of showing that
going alone is usually a mistake this is
especially relevant for Stingray who
cuts himself off from his former friends
out of fear and only speaks out against
Terry silver after being bolstered by
them the shirt can also be read as a
foreshadowing of the sword fight that
takes place between Chosen and silver in
the Cobra Kai season 5 finale a tease
that chosen's habit of bringing his Sai
everywhere with him is a smart idea
though the duel between Daniel and Terry
silver is the proper final battle of
Cobra Kai season 5 the real action
climax is the sword fight between silver
and chosen no prior battle in the show
can match it in terms of absurdity or
stakes and if you are watching the whole
season closely you might have seen it
coming early in season 5 when chosen is
still undercover as a Sensei at the main
Cobra Kai Dojo he's invited by silver
for dinner at his house while he's there
the villain shows him his impressive
collection of Swords including one that
he later uses to nearly fight chosen to
the death this is about as true an
example of chekhov's gun as you can
possibly get save for the fact that it's
a sword instead of a gun The Narrative
principle associated with playwright
Anton Chekhov asserts that a gun scene
hanging over a fireplace in the First
Act of a play must be fired in the third
act and Cobra Kai Silver's swords are
literally presented as display pieces
exactly as a gun would be if hung over a
fireplace this clever use of the old
Trope foreshadows Chosen and Silver's
eventual duel and it makes it all the
more satisfying when it finally happens
Cobra Kai season 5 does a fair bit of
foreshadowing including one musical
illusion at the end of episode nine
chosen Daniel and Johnny get back in
their rented party limo to head to
another bar leading to a drunken
sing-along to the survivor's iconic 80s
hit Eye of the Tiger on a purely surface
level this song is almost too
appropriate as the oscar-nominated theme
song of Rocky 3 it fits perfectly for
the three Sensei all of whom have been
on journeys of self-discovery throughout
the show in other words they haven't
lost their grip on the dreams of the
past and they've certainly risen up to
the challenge of their Rivals however
there's a second level of meaning to the
song choice that foreshadows the events
of episodes 9 and 10. Survivor vocalist
David bickler sings the lyrics the last
known Survivor stalks his prey in the
night and he's watching us all with the
eye of the tiger these lyrics play just
as it's revealed that the limo has been
hijacked by an unseen presumably
malicious Force then toward the
beginning of episode 10 we see shots of
Terry silver acting villainous the
song's lyrics are clearly meant to imply
that the big bad is the one stalking Our
Heroes given Johnny's outspoken
obsession with Rocky the whole sequence
is spot on
in the final battle between Daniel and
Terry silver at the end of Cobra Kai
season 5 silver taunts his opponent by
saying that miyagido will soon be
extinct Daniel isn't phased by this the
roots are strong
while not quite the original phrasing
the sentiment of Daniel's statement
Echoes Mr miyagi's own words of
encouragement from The Karate Kid Part
3. in the movie Daniel is Led down a
dark path by Silver's manipulative
schemes but he eventually realizes the
error in his ways feeling weak and
broken he returns to Mr Miyagi with a
mountain of guilt at all that he's done
but his mentor doesn't allow him to
wallow in shame instead he shows him the
special bonsai tree broken by Mike
Barnes earlier in the film which Mr
Miyagi has repotted and helped to
flourish Daniel is astonished that the
tree is doing so well that's when
Daniel's Mentor says his iconic line
strong root
just like you Danielson by invoking this
bit of wisdom from his old teacher
Daniel isn't just calling to mind Mr
miyagi's training he's specifically
Conjuring the feelings that allowed him
to defeat Silver schemes as a kid so
that he can defeat him once again as an
adult and clearly his strategy works
Cobra Kai has always been a show that
enjoys narrative parallels but season 5
takes things to a whole other level
there are some obvious cases like how
Miguel and Robbie's rivalry turned
friendship acts as a sped up version of
Johnny and Daniel's Arc or how there are
a half dozen Mentor Protege
relationships that mirror each other
across the cast season 5 adds additional
parallelism however in the form of its
many reformed villains by bringing
Johnny Chosen and Mike Barnes together
Cobra Kai makes a team of Daniel's three
main Rivals from the original film
Trilogy and while some get more screen
time than others their Journeys parallel
each other and Daniels in several ways
like Johnny chosen wallowed in
self-loathing for years albeit with a
bit more remorse and like Daniel Mike
found solace in the joys of being a
small business owner additionally season
5 adds layers to the show's existing
family parallels Johnny and Miguel's
relationship continues to mirror Mr
Miyagi and Daniel's surrogate father-son
Bond especially after Miguel sees what
kind of man his biological father really
is and Tori gets to skip the years of
English felt by The Karate Kid movie
villains by admitting her mistakes to
Sam and seeking peace there's a lot of
silliness in Cobra guys season 5 but
there's also a lot of intense
directors is all woven together
[Music]